[Music]
what's like the most scorpion thing
you've done i lit my ex's
clothes on fire you didn't let him on
fire or them on fire so
no
we brought together seven scorpios i'm a
scorpio i'm a scorpio i'm a scorpio i'm
a scorpio i am a scorpio i'm a scorpio
i'm a scorpio one is a liar if the group
discovers who the liar is they'll split
a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who is the odd one out
[Music]
so should we go around and say birthdays
starting with me yeah sure november 7th
november 14th october 28th we have the
same birthday really yeah whenever mindy
said that her birthday was the same as
mine i was kind of like that's
interesting is it or are you just saying
that november 1st november 21st october
27th do people think like you're a mean
person like because of just your face
yeah i was going to stay like a
stereotype you just automatically have
rbf you know
yeah yeah i've been told like oh when i
first met you i was super intimidated by
you yeah yeah
scorpios are very like
sarcastic their humor is dry witty you
look for people who are very shy
reserved you know into themselves
do you guys have any tattoos yeah i have
two of this one and scorpio one so oh no
what is that of oh um so it's a skeleton
with the scorpion's tail and then it
says never trust a living because
scorpios you know they don't trust
anybody so you know she says she's a
scorpio and has some scorpio tattoos
like oh it could be like her other
scorpio placements that she really loves
and so she tattooed it on herself or
something it's dedicated to beetlejuice
because never trust the living is also
that's like one of my favorite movies
[Music]
she was the most shy of the group she
was very reserved and that kind of stuck
out to me the most he just kind of
seemed like he knew who he was and was
trying to show it immediately
i figured if the mole was going to do
something they were going to just
piggyback off of somebody's birthday so
[Music]
when i said that i had the same birthday
as her i was like i'm i'm out i'm the
first one out already i knew it do y'all
like believe in astrology in general oh
it's my job
really yeah that's so cool i've been
interested in it ever since i was a
little girl so it just kind of it was a
path
so you could be very well versed in all
of the signs
no because there are certain signs that
i do not like and i do not study but you
know a gemini is a gemini for a reason
giselle pointed it out and i was like ah
i shouldn't have said that i don't know
anything about any other sign except for
mine
if there's a post then i'll look for
scorpios yeah
obviously that's the only one that
matters
i'm gonna be honest i don't really
believe in astrology
so my main thing was just to be like
confident about their birthday anything
like that then that was a green flag for
me what's like the most scorpion thing
you've done i lit my ex's clothes on
fire okay yeah
you didn't let him on fire or them on
fire so
no
i was just gonna say i guess the most
scorpio thing i've done is like i've
deleted all social media and i kind of
just went ghost for a while oh my god i
did that this year oh really yeah do you
all have any scorpio characteristics
that you don't fit like for me i know
that scorpios are supposed to be like
really sexual and stuff and i'm actually
asexual so something in the alignment
got messed up for me everything about
scorpio like that's just me that's so
bad i feel like when you are talking
about signs not everybody embodies all
of the characteristics but he was just
like hitting every single point so i was
like okay
interesting noted i feel like i'm the
same as him i feel like i just kind of
i'm a theater student well i guess that
you know just being out in the open
performing i'm still introverted but but
you like being the center of attention
doing all that yeah well not attention
just on stage
i feel like it just lets out the energy
that i have pent up
when i was grabbing a paper i looked
inside the box really quick and i saw my
name written down so i knew obviously it
was her cause she was the only one
before me that's literally the reason
why you voted for her yep because she
voted for you yep he just said that he
fit all of the scorpio stereotypes and
that's kind of an easy out
we have a tie
the tie is between erica and chris
i was very surprised
i was like oh okay so nobody trusts me
like that means we're going into a
second round of votes
this is bs i don't know like what about
me
gave it away to them that like if i
wasn't a scorpio or something like the
mole but i felt like i was being very
true to myself if everyone feels
confident that you already caught them
all you can end the game now but if the
majority has doubt the game will
continue please raise your hand if you
want to continue playing the game
starting now
for every time all of you vote out
someone that is not the mole the total
prize money will be reduced
um so for me i was when i was working at
a restaurant one of my co-workers was
like what's your sign and i was like i'm
a scorpio and they looked at me and
they're like i can tell you have scorpio
eyes
and i have no idea what that means
scorpios have like a very like precise
dare so when you like look at somebody
it's like you're staring through their
soul yeah that happens to me a lot like
i actually worked with my sister and we
were working a shift together and she's
just like yo i pass by you you look mean
i feel like people
know that i'm a water sign but i feel
like they just mistake it for like
cancer actually only cancer or like
taurus or something but taurus isn't a
water sign though that's a that's an
earth sign my dude so yeah my coworker
they were like a scorpio is just a
cancer and a leather jacket and i
laughed at that statement until this day
do you guys think your like style
reflects your sign at all or not really
oh no because scorpios are supposed to
be like really like mysterious or
something but yeah and i'm just like i'm
like erica badu over here
have you guys ever had like a wild party
moment there was this halloween party i
guess i got really drunk and i was
trying to cool down it was someone
else's house so i went in the the front
where no one was there and i just passed
out no i'm like i don't i don't party
down
oh maybe he's a cancer or a tourist
instead of scorpio just acting like he's
a scorpio or something
his stories just kind of did not add up
in my opinion
[Music]
if everyone feels confident that you
already caught them all you can end the
game now but if the majority has doubt
the game will continue
okay majority does not want to continue
so we will end the game
now
if the light turns green that means you
have voted out the mole and you win if
the lights turn red that means the mole
is still in the box and you lose
[Music]
i knew it
i told you so i said that we should keep
going
i was right and you were wrong betrayed
by my own self
well the fake scorpio please step
forward and reveal yourself in three
two
one
[Music]
i knew it i knew it i knew it i am the
only worst sign that there is uh gemini
when she started mentioning that i got
scared but my sister's actually the
scorpio so we're just uh channeling her
personality currently
i'm so nervous
i feel like it's the most gemini thing
i've ever done i really don't want to
bring hate to the sign but like didn't
know that i would coast as far as i did
sweating the whole time my intuition
like told me was her since round one i
was just like i just questioned myself a
lot on that one you two you mentioned um
where's your tat this is fake my friend
drew it on me for this other wrist yeah
i was looking at it and i was like it
looks like a stencil with the sharpie
yeah it's honestly just like eyeliner
that's such gemini behavior it is gemini
behavior
we want to thank all of you for
participating so we're going to give you
all a gift these are bags for you guys
thank you
it just says
[Music]
thank you natalia because i'm channeling
your energy right now
[Music]
i